[Music]
selamat pagi
anyhow hello today I would like to talk
to you about web components and an
experimental JavaScript API called the
accessibility object model or a om when
we load some HTML into the browser
several things happen more or less at
the same time the HTML gets translated
into the Dom tree it also gets
translated into the accessibility tree
and finally it gets translated into the
user interface the part that we can see
and we can interact with so if we take a
button element our HTML is very very
simple just open and close the button
elements with some text content in the
middle our Dom looks exactly the same we
see that element is a node in the Dom
tree and the text leaf in the middle
when we look at the accessibility tree
we get more information about this node
and the node in the accessibility tree
for this button element says that it has
a role of button but its accessible name
is play that's the text inside the
button element and that it's state is
focusable so if you use a keyboard and
not a mouse or trackpad you can use the
tab key to focus on the button and
interact with it our UI then presents a
button on the screen that we can click
or interact with with a keyboard or
touchpad and with a bit of styling it
looks hopefully reasonably presentable
so if we were to try and create a button
elements using a web component there are
a couple of ways we could do this we
could use a customized custom element
this takes the HTML button element and
extends it so it means that when we set
up our web component our constructor is
really simple we just call super because
that's good practice in web components
and we don't need to do anything else
apart from give our custom element a
name in this case custom dash button if
you're not familiar we
web components and custom elements they
must always have a dash in their name
and this is just to help the browser
separate a native HTML element from the
HTML spec from one that we've created as
developers through the custom elements
API our connected callback is also
really simple we don't need to do very
much at all we just need to add some
click functionality to make button work
and that's pretty much all there is to
it our HTML however looks a little bit
ugly we use the button elements as we
would in standard HTML but we add the is
attribute to it so we say button is
custom button so our HTML has already
grown another attribute which is not too
terrible but it's not as clean in code
terms as we might like it to be Dom
looks pretty much exactly the same
nothing much changes in that translation
and accessibility tree also looks pretty
much the same it still says it's the
thing with a roll of button the text is
still its accessible name and it's still
focusable so effectively what we've done
is just recreate the button element as a
custom element and we can see this work
pretty much like you'd expect a button
to work only this time we'll hear a
screen reader announce the button to
play button and the screen reader picks
up that information from the
accessibility tree it recognizes the
accessible name play and it recognizes
it that it's a button and tells the user
that information there's a problem
though apart from the fact that the HTML
looks a little bit less clean than we
want it to be customized custom elements
are not particularly well supported
they're not supported in WebKit Apple is
pretty firmly opposed to introducing
support for customized custom elements
so we might have to turn our attention
to autonomous custom elements now an
autonomous custom element doesn't extend
an existing HTML element so we can't
inherit all the good behavior from say
button that we just did with the
customized element instead we have to
start pretty much from scratch and that
means we've got to do all the work that
the browser does for us normally for
ourselves
so in constructor
need to set things up a little bit
differently you'll notice that the the
definition is slightly different this
time I'm going to create a toggle button
as well you may have noticed from the
video we just played that that button
looked different when it was pressed but
the screen reader didn't pick up on that
information so we're gonna set about
creating that toggle button so the
definition has changed to be a toggle -
button this time and if we look at the
connected callback there's an awful lot
more going on inside it we need to set
the role just using setattribute so
that's the bit that fills in the
accessibility role we need to set
tabindex to zero that's the bit that
will make our custom element focusable
with the keyboard and we add in an aria
attribute aria-pressed and we set it
initially to false this is the attribute
that will tell screen readers and inform
the accessibility tree that this is a
different kind of button it's one that
can be turned on or off and we'll see
how that develops we have a function
into the click and keyboard event
handlers and we're just gonna switch the
status of the aria-pressed attribute
over so when someone uses the keyboard
or the mouse to interact with the button
will flip the value to true while it's
pressed and flip it back again to false
when it's not pressed and this will
change the accessibility state
information in the accessibility tree so
our HTML looks a lot more simple we just
open and close our toggle - button
elements and we still put the text on
the inside our Dom however it starts to
look a little bit messy we see all the
attributes we've just set inside the
custom elements that have indexed the
role the aria-pressed they actually leak
out from the custom element into the Dom
so unfortunately here things start to
get a bit more messy looking our
accessibility tree has also changed a
little bit the type of the button the
role of the button is now toggle button
in some browsers and some accessibility
API is it's known as a push button so
this is just a different type of button
everything else is pretty much the same
but the state now also has a recognition
of the fact that this button can be
pressed or not pressed so there is more
named States and roll
information available in the
accessibility tree in the browser when a
screen reader or another assistive
technology queries that information from
the browser the experience for the user
changes quite dramatically play toggle
button not pressed pressed not pressed
so we now have a custom element that is
a toggle button it has all the
accessibility characteristics that we
need to inform something like a screen
reader that it's a toggle button and the
user now gets to understand when that
button is pressed and when it's not so
the experience is a lot better for
someone who can't see the visual state
of the button changing here's where we
come to that experimental JavaScript API
I mentioned the AOM is still relatively
new it's being developed in the web
platform incubator community group ycg
at the w3c and it's being worked on by
people from Apple Mozilla and Google and
it's a JavaScript API that will let us
get involved in that relationship that I
mentioned in the very first slide that
until now has only happened within the
browser so up till now the accessibility
tree has only ever been created by the
browser and the only thing that has
access to that accessibility tree other
than the browser our assistive
technologies like screen readers for the
first time now as developers through the
AOM JavaScript API we're about to get
access to that tree ourselves and that
opens up a lot of different
possibilities and also a few challenges
and things that we're going to need to
be aware of phase one is going to
introduce Aria reflection it means we're
going to be able to set different roles
and attributes and have them reflected
back so it keeps things much simpler and
lets us use more familiar JavaScript
syntax so for reflecting the attributes
there are two interface mix-ins that
have actually been added not only to the
AOM specification but they will also be
added to one point two of the Aria
specification Aria is accessible rich
Internet applications and these two
interface mix-ins will let us reflect
back rolls and other Aria attributes
so if we rewrite our connected callback
for the toggle button we can see the
change in syntax instead of having to
use set attribute we can use element dot
roll equals button to set the the role
of the element we can use element dots
tabindex equals 0 and element
aria-pressed 'false notice though that
the way tabindex & aria-pressed written
has changed there's now a capital I on
the index of tabindex where there
wouldn't normally be and the dash has
gone from the Aria dashed pressed
attribute and instead it two uses
camelcase
so all of these Aria attributes have a
slightly different way of being written
but they achieve pretty much the same
thing we set all those properties and
characteristics exactly as we did in the
earlier example we can also or we will
be able to set element references now
this is where we get into the part that
is still so experimental it doesn't
actually exist in the browser's yet not
even behind the flag but what we'd be
able to do is where we have an element
sorry an attribute like Aria described
by which up till now you can use to
point to another piece of content on the
page using its ID value as the reference
point and it will associate that piece
of text with the first element so
typical example is you focus on a form
filled with a screen reader you'll here
the label of the form field announced
the type of the form field announced and
then you could use Aria described by to
associate an extra hint to help someone
fill out that information and the screen
reader would automatically read that out
to putting ID references on things is
often quite heavy weights you can have
hundreds sometimes thousands in a heavy
application of ID references on a page
but what will happen in the future is
that we'll be able to use just plain
JavaScript element references in our
code instead of having to use ID
references so for example we'll be able
to use Aria described by elements to
feed it one or more reference points for
the information we want to hook up in
the user interface but as I say this is
experimental yet we can't play around
with this feature if you're curious
there is a series of harness of web
platform tests available for
one a at the moment if you take a look
at it in Chrome or the new edge chromium
beta you'll find that about 65 out of
the 95 tests are currently passing so
that's all the attribute and role
reflections but none of the element
reflections Safari is doing really well
with about 79 interestingly WebKit
Safari has taken out from behind the
flag so this works actually at the
production level in Chrome it's still
behind the AOM accessibility flag
Firefox hasn't yet introduced any
support behind the flag or otherwise but
I'm pretty sure it will catch up soon so
hitting those tests in your browser is a
pretty good way to keep up to date with
how much of phase one is currently
available to play with phase one B
introduces custom element semantics now
the idea behind this phase is that we
can start to clean up some of that Dom
leakage that we saw with our toggle
button example we don't want all the
tabindex the role the Aria press to the
other attributes to leak out into the
Dom when we create a custom element we
want to keep the accessibility
encapsulated so this is the part of the
spec that will let us do that in two
different ways ultimately we'll be able
to set accessibility characteristics at
the time the custom element is created
and ones that can be adapted and changed
in the element internals so for example
we could change our code slightly so
that element definitions options include
things like setting the role and the
tabindex because we want those to be
established in the custom element the
moment it's created exactly as though we
were using a standard HTML button
element we can then do per instance
semantics using an internals variable we
can attach the internals in the
constructor for the custom element and
that lets us set things that will change
through the course of the custom
elements lifetime so aria-pressed will
change in response to user interactions
so we set that here instead of as an
immutable characteristic in the element
definition options but as I say
unfortunately at the moment we still
can't play with this just yet
phase two is all about user interactions
and events we're all really used to
events like click key down key press a
whole bunch of others but when you
introduce an assistive technology like a
screen reader into the equation things
get a little bit more complicated so
they are going to change the way that
events are synthesized and also
introduced some new events the reason
for the synthesis is to protect the
privacy of assistive technology users so
if they were just to create some
assistive technology events it would
very very easy to detect not only that
the user was using a particular
assistive technology but what type of
assistive technology they were using and
that of course would make it very easy
to determine that the person was blind
because they're using a screen reader
had mobility impairments because they're
using speech recognition and so
obviously it's important that we protect
that user privacy so what happens is
when someone using a screen reader
carries out an action it will synthesize
a click event for example so
particularly on touch devices if you tap
a device with a screen reader running
it's a double tap gesture not a single
tap that you'll be used to but that will
synthesize a click event and similarly
other events are cloaked if you like
using these synthesized events they're
also going to introduce some new events
particularly increment and decrement
scroll up scroll down and dismiss and
this very much plays into touchscreen
devices at the moment it's pretty much
impossible to create a custom slider
using all the accessibility
characteristics that are available and
to have it usable with a screen reader
on a touch device the reason is that
when you have a screen reader running on
your touch screen flick up and flick
down the gestures you'd probably use to
adjust the value of a slider are already
used for screen reader specific commands
so there's no way that those commands
can be separated out into using a slider
they're always protected they're always
ring-fenced for the screen reader so if
you go to something like the Aria
authoring practice
guide and pick up the blueprint design
pattern for a slider there implement it
perfectly but try to use it on a
touchscreen device with the screen
reader running it won't work the slider
can't be adjusted in the way that you'd
expect so these are being put into
practice these new events will come
along to help us get around that problem
phase 3 will let us introduce virtual
accessibility nodes into the tree this
is where we really start to get our
hands on that browser only functionality
will be able to add entirely new nodes
into the accessibility tree up until
this point there is always a
corresponding Dom node for an
accessibility node but we can change
that this is the bit where it starts to
feel really scary what we don't want to
happen is for developers to start
creating entirely secondary
accessibility trees just for screen
reader users that bear no resemblance to
the Dom good practice is always going to
be to try and keep those two things
synchronized with each other but one
really clear use case is doing something
with the canvas element when we draw
something to the screen using canvas
it's all done in JavaScript so there are
no HTML elements there's no
accessibility semantics that are
available to the accessibility tree and
so two screen readers so one use of
being able to add virtual nodes to the
accessibility tree is that we can attach
a shadow root to the canvas element we
can then start adding a virtual branch
of the accessibility tree in there to
provide fullback content specifically
for people who can't see the JavaScript
rendered content inside the canvas
element but this is a long way off now
and there's a lot of obstacles to
getting to this point but it really does
have some interesting possibilities
phase four lastly is probably the most
complicated of all the phases it's going
to give us access to all computed
accessibility properties in the
accessibility tree both for the
accessibility nodes that are associated
with Dom nodes but also for the entire
accessibility tree we'll be able to walk
through the accessibility tree in the
same way that we can walk the Dom now so
again it's going to open up a lot of
possibilities for functionality and
capability but I think they're keeping
this one till the last phase because it
is the one that's going to take the most
discussion the most thinking
so looking at those things this is how
we can think about building
accessibility into our custom elements
recognizing that if we use autonomous
custom elements we need to add in the
accessibility characteristics for
ourselves and that the AO M in time is
going to give us a lot more flexibility
to do that but we can also use custom
elements in fact the whole web component
stack to solve accessibility problems as
well sorry so we can create a speak
content element for example I use a
screen reader and one thing I quite
often do is if I want to look at the
news I will go and set my screen reader
reading a news item on the website and
then I'll go off and make myself a cup
of tea while I'm still listening to it
because I don't need to look at the
screen my screen reader on my headset is
portable I can just walk around the
house put the kettle on make the tea and
still listen to the news story and I've
often thought this would be a really
useful thing for everybody to be able to
do being tied to your chair to your
computer your laptop is not always the
ideal experience so perhaps we can use
custom elements to create a widget that
will let us have a button on screen that
will read a designated piece of content
out loud and it turns out it's
reasonably easy to achieve we can use
the HTML template element to set up the
actual element we'll chuck some styling
in there just to make the the button and
the div look good we will also use some
slots to manage things so in the
template we've got a button element that
contains a slot element and this will
let us pull through content from the
light Dom from the the developer code
and we'll also set up a div that's also
going to be a slot for the content that
we want to be spoken out loud
in our connected callback we will do all
sorts of things we will grab the control
the thing we'll hit to make it speak
we'll grab the element that contains the
content and then from there we'll grab
the content that we want to be spoken
out loud in our function we will set up
the web speech API to make it talk we'll
create
since this is object and will attach to
that to the text that we want spoken out
loud that we've grabbed from the light
Dom and then lastly we need to set a
timeout because what we want to do is
lastly make the button look like it's
been pressed for as long as the contents
being spoken and then we want to return
it to its default States when it's
finished we're using the aria-pressed
attribute again to make sure that that
happens in the accessibility state as
well as the visual state reset state
then just checks after 500 milliseconds
and it checks to see if the speech uh
pterence is still talking if it is still
talking it resets the timer for another
500 if it isn't then it returns the
state of the button back to non pressed
would you one last bit of under the hood
magic and we're going to attach the
visual state of the button to the
attribute selector using aria-pressed so
as the value of aria-pressed is changed
the visual style of the button changes
accordingly and it just makes the whole
thing sync up a lot more easily under
the hood and what we get at the end of
it is a very simple piece of text on
page a button that we can hit and
hopefully everything all works for
everybody one tequila two tequila three
tequila floor and so custom elements
hopefully this has given you a brief
insight into can be used not only as I
said to solve accessibility problems but
if we get them right add in all the
accessibility properties that we need to
they give us a really powerful way to
create new and useful features on the
web I need to really thank a couple of
people Scott O'Hara and Patrick Walker
and Dan Hopkins who all gave me a
tremendous amount of help while I was
putting this together there's a URL
on-screen from Pat which leads to a way
to implement a slider that will work in
accessibility terms on touchscreen
devices you basically use a native
slider element you hook it up to the
custom visuals that you want to make
sure you keep it all in sync but if
you're curious about an interim solution
until the aom arrives
that's a really good one to check but
otherwise I recommend that you follow
all of these people they're all damn
good developers in their own right and
pretty damn good people too and lastly
thank you very much to all of you
[Applause]